[Music]
hi my name is Tarun Singh and I work at
Microsoft Research Redman lab in this
particular demo that I'm going to show
you today I'm going to show you the
power of private compute using
homomorphic encryption consider this
scenario let's say if you are a hospital
there's a lot of patient data but no
machine learning capability in contrast
to the hospital
we have Microsoft that has all the AI
capability in the world but the
hospitals cannot currently make use of
our capabilities going to the privacy
concerns around sharing patient data
what if there was a way to actually
share patient data with Microsoft be
able to use our AI capabilities without
compromising the privacy of patients so
let's say if you have a patient named
jonathan they have a lot of information
about him and we want to predict if he's
going to get pneumonia or not so what
you can do is you can use our seal
library this is a form of morphic
encryption library you can use that to
encrypt the patient data now you can see
the encrypted data does not look like
the original data in any shape or form
nobody can decrypt it you can transfer
the encrypted data back to Azure and we
can run machine learning predictions on
encrypted data so let's do that
and we have the encrypted predictions -
once again the beauty is that even
though Microsoft Randi prediction is
using their machine learning model we
cannot really understand what the model
is predicted it's all encrypted we send
the encrypted results back to the
customers those are the only people who
can decrypt it they decrypt the results
and I find that the patient is not going
to get pneumonia
- once again they have been able to use
Microsoft ai capability there was no
compromising of patient privacy at all
and they have been able to use a
state-of-the-art machine learning model
and that is the power of private compute
[Music]
you